a food scientist wants to estimate the
difference between the mean weights of
eggs classified as jumbo and large they
plan on taking a sample of each type of
egg to construct a to sample T interval
which of the following are conditions
for this type of interval so before I
even look at these choices and they say
choose all answers that apply so it
might be more than one let's just think
about what the conditions for inference
for this type of interval actually are
so we've done this many times in many
different contexts and so we first of
all have the random condition and that's
the idea that each of our samples are
random or we are conducting some type of
an experiment where we randomly assign
folks to one or eggs in this case to one
of two groups in this case we are taking
two samples and we would hope that they
are truly random samples the second is
the normal condition and the normal
condition is a little bit different
depending on whether we're talking about
means or whether we're talking about
proportions the random condition is
essentially the same the normal
condition when we're talking about means
remember they're looking at the
difference between mean weights of eggs
is you would want your there's actually
a several ways to meet the normal
condition one is is if the underlying
distribution is normal the second way is
if your sample sizes for each of your
samples are greater than or equal to 30
so if your first sample size is greater
than or equal to 30 and your second
sample size is greater than or equal to
30 or even if the underlying data you
don't know whether it's normal or it
isn't normal and even if you aren't able
to meet these as long as your sample
data is roughly symmetric and not skewed
heavily in one way or the other
then that also roughly meets the normal
condition when we're dealing with means
and in the third condition and we see
this whether we're dealing with means or
proportions or differences of means or
differences of portions is the
independence condition and this is the
idea that either your individual
observations are done with replacement
in both of yours
samples or that the sample size for both
of your samples is no more than 10% of
the population then you have met this
condition so with that little bit of a
review let's see which of these apply
they observe at least 10 heavy eggs and
10 light eggs in each sample so this
actually is the normal condition when we
are dealing with proportions not 4 means
so I would rule this out it's a good
distractor choice the eggs in each
sample are randomly selected from their
population yep that's the random
condition right over there so I would
select that they sample an equal number
of each type of egg so this is a common
misconception that whether we're dealing
with means or proportions when we're
thinking about the difference between
say means or the difference between
proportions that somehow your sample
sizes have to be the exact same that is
not the case your sample sizes do not
have to be the exact case or I do not
have to be the exact same so we would
rule this out as well
so right over here they have listed the
random condition they could have also
listed the normal condition and the
independence condition